[موسيقى]
تذوق فريق ماركوس استمرت جهوده عندما تمكن
من استقطاب الناشئين واستطاع تنميه الجانب
التكنولوجي لديهم ورافقهم وهم يحملون
روبوتاتهم التي صنعوها بايديهم بعزيمه
وثقه الى المسابقات الدوليه ليفوز بالعديد
من جوائزها تدعم الفريق تقنيا منظمه اتقان
للتكنولوجيا وهي مؤسسه غير ربحيه تهتم
بانشاء وتوسيع شبكه من الفرق لتبادل
الخبرات والمعرفه والنشر الشفف بالعلوم
والتكنولوجيا والهندسه والرياضيات تضم
منظمه اتقان نخبه من المتطوعين المتميزين
الذين يقدمون منحا مجانيه في مجالات
البرمجه والذكاء الصناعي والتصميم الهندسي
والاعلان وتقدم المنح بشرط اجتياز
الاختبارات ثم تتم المتقدمين للوصول الى
افضل النماذج التي ستشارك في المسابقات
المحليه والدوليه
المبادره اثمرت احراز فريق ماركوس امتوارث
نتائج متقدمه في بطوله الشمال تكساس التي
اشترك فيها اكثر من 170 فريقا متنافسا
يمثلون المدارس الثانويه الحكوميه والخاصه
كما شارك فريقان من فرق المنظمه في تصفيات
بطوله كولورادو ونال احدهما المركز الاول
فيها وكوفي الفريق بحصول كل عضو فيه على
منحه دراسيه من جامعه رجس مدتها اربع
سنوات
انا مبرمجه فريق مارفلز واحب ان الهم
الفريق واعطيهم الفرصه ليصبح قاده في
المستقبل
مبادره انطلقت من المجتمعات المسلمه في
الولايات المتحده فاصبحت فرصه للتبادل
المعرفي والثقافي بين المجتمع المسلم
والمجتمعات الاخرى لم يتوقف سقف طموح
المبادره فوصلت الى الشباب والاطفال في
القاهره وعينها على جميع الشباب في العالم
العربي لايمانها بالاثر الكبير
للتكنولوجيا والابتكار في التعامل مع
التحديات العلميه والاقتصاديه التي
تواجهها المنطقه العربيه